you all seem comfortable are you
comfortable you know you know why you're
comfortable because you're not in the
Midwest right now that's crazy
what's happening in your from Chicago
yeah it's it's you're seeing like -28
yeah exactly
polar vortex is crippling the Midwest
apparently it came in from Canada anyone
here from Canada yeah thanks a lot yeah
thank you
keep your for Jack keep your vortex all
right good I know it's you're polite
it's nice to share but keys are for Tess
we're building our wall on the wrong
border yeah you know it's it's it's even
colder it's minus 45 Wow in some places
yeah there is a state of emergency in
Wisconsin yep yes not because of the
cold but because someone eat a vegetable
he's a Brussels sprout apparently
National Guard has been called in the
Old Kingdom while they're down I'm
watching this right now I'm such an
but you know people who would
probably feel pretty good right now in
the Midwest are people who let
themselves go over the holiday or that
mean for them this is shorts weather
yeah this is insulation yep and anyone
who like got on that crazy diet they're
dead right now this is a true story in
Chicago people are being robbed at
gunpoint just for their down jackets
that's a true story people are robbing
people at gunpoint just to get their
down jacket a summer the people are like
look I've got a wallet with $30,000 in
it and the robbers like I don't want it
I want the down jacket what is it called
it what's the popular the jacket that
they all want what's that how come
everyone knows the name of this down
jacket it's Canada goose why is it such
a big deal wait a minute the vortex is
from Canada and the jacket is Canada
goose
it's a scam it's all about selling check
Hey
are you saying canada invented the
vortex yes and sent it south as if they
could sell right some Canadian down
jackets Canadians are very devious you
know what they're known as a devious
devious now all of this is hard to
relate to cuz you know
the coldest it gets in LA is when you
wake up in the morning and think maybe I
should put on socks that's as cold as it
gets here right that's all we have to
worry about huh did you go socks today
or socks lists no socks today it's jelly
yeah I'm socks no underwear
now it's it's for a medical thing I told
you to save your woo and once again you
misspent it